تم قصف كراماتورسك خلال الليل
بستة صواريخ على الأقل الآن كان
لها تأثير مدمر بشكل واضح ، وهذا هو
تدفئة منطقة الصرف الصحي لمحطة ضخ
بحجم المبنى مما يشير إلى
أنه لا يمكن بأي حال من الأحوال أن يضم
أي نوع من المعدات العسكرية التي
حصلت عليها للتو  كنت محظوظًا ، لقد ذهبت إلى الحمام ، لقد
سمعت صوتًا
قويًا جلست على السرير وضربني
وسقط كل الأثاث ،
لكن المشاهد هنا
غير عادية تمامًا بالطريقة التي
تم بها قطع رأس هذه الأشجار تمامًا
إلى أشلاء ونفس الشيء ينطبق
أيضًا
بالنسبة لهذه المنازل
الآن بشكل مثير للدهشة ، هناك عدد قليل جدًا من الأشخاص هنا
نظرًا لحجم الأضرار التي لحقت بهم
ولم يقتل أي منهم ، هناك
25 مصابًا ستة تم نقلهم إلى المستشفى
أحدهم في حالة حرجة
والسبب في ذلك هو أن
ثلثي المدينة على الأقل  من كرامرتورسك
قد غادر بالفعل ولكن هذا دون أي
سؤال هو ضربة أخرى من قبل
الروس على منطقة سكنية مدنية
سام كيلي سي إن إن في كراماتوسك